check this out this is a chinese-built
railway in the heart of Kenya yep you
heard that right the sgr from Nairobi to
Mombasa was built by Chinese developers
and paid for by Kenya mostly through
Chinese loans to the tune of 3.6 billion
dollars the idea was to create a cheaper
and faster connection between the two
cities through a railway that Kenya
hoped would essentially pay for itself
except so far it hasn't and the reason
why is a great example of why China is
revamping its ambitious Belton Road
Project let me explain
[Music]
so wsj recently published this great
story on how after loaning out around a
trillion dollars in almost 150 countries
Chinese policymakers are now reassessing
belt and road projects by more
rigorously evaluating new projects for
financing and Kenya's SDR is just a
great example of why they're doing that
2008 Kenya launched its Vision 2030
economic revitalization plan part of
which was a plan to build a new standard
gauge Railway or sgr from the port of
Mombasa to the landlocked neighboring
countries of Uganda and Rwanda around
the same time China wanted to invest in
foreign countries infrastructure to
create new markets for Chinese Goods
fast forward to around 2014 and China's
state-owned China Road and Bridge
Corporation won a contract from Kenya
without any competitive bidding to build
phase one of the project a 300 mile
stretch from ambassador to Nairobi upon
completion of the standard gauge Railway
line transport costs in the region are
expected to reduce by more than 60
percent China is ready to share her
experiences to pay China Road and Bridge
Corporation or CRBC Kenya took out a 3.6
billion dollar loan from China's exim
Bank the idea was that revenue from the
new sgr line would be used to pay back
the loan and to try and make sure it was
profitable all Kenya's Port Authority
made a commitment to guarantee that a
certain amount of cargo would travel
along the line remember this point we'll
be coming back to it later
work started around 2014 Chinese
concrete and steel was imported into
Kenya and then in 2017 18 months ahead
of schedule and just in time for Kenya's
elections the railway was finished
but here's the thing since it opened
Kenya's sgr has struggled to be
profitable by 2020 it had lost some 200
million dollars not ideal for a railway
that's supposed to be paying for itself
so what happened well I've been waiting
through these documents to try and find
out to start with Kenya's government
officials questioned whether the country
received good value for money because
CRBC was awarded the contract without
any other competition what's more in
2013 when the World Bank published a
study into building the standard gauge
Railway in Kenya they found there was no
economical Financial case to do so see
for the new sgr to pay for itself it has
to move a lot of cargo some analysts
estimate over 20 million tons a year and
the World Bank estimated between 20 and
55 million tons and it just doesn't move
that much that's partly because phase
one of the Railway development ended at
Nairobi and didn't connect up with
Rwanda and Uganda but it's also because
alongside the railway line runs a road
and that's how a lot of cargo is moved
so to try and get cargo off the roads
and onto the train and uphold its
guarantees Kenya's Port Authority
ordered that cargo headed to Nairobi or
further north had to be transported
there via the sgr it led to protests
from Mombasa locals and truck drivers
and still even with that order the sgr
didn't move enough cargo to be
profitable fast forward to today and
President William Ruto has reversed the
order which means the sgr could soon be
carrying even less cargo that casts more
doubt over whether the train will ever
be economically sustainable and able to
pay for itself Kenya's Treasury and Port
Authority and China's CRBC and exim Bank
didn't respond to buy a request for
comments and can your Railways referred
me to their managing director who didn't
respond either as of June 2021 Kenya
still owed 3.3 billion of the initial
3.6 billion dollars borrowed and that's
just part of Kenya's debt to China and
it's that combined with other expensive
and underutilized infrastructure
projects that China has lent money to
that has led to some Chinese policy
makers rethinking belt and road projects
so are we still going to see China
lending out huge sums for transportation
projects around the world after all some
analysts I spoke to said projects like
the thika superhighway in Kenya were
actually relatively successful well
earlier I headed into the office to
speak to my wsja YouTube colleague
Shelby Holliday who covers geopolitics
she has been looking into Belton roads
rebranding well Chinese officials
acknowledge that Belton Road as they
initially imagined it is just not
sustainable not only has it left some
countries with mountains of debt but
it's also hurt Chinese Banks since
they're having a hard time getting their
money back Shelby told me that Chinese
officials are now looking to Rebrand the
whole initiative as Belton Road 2.0 and
if you want to know what that looks like
outside of Transport go and check out
Shelby's video it's basically a more
conservative version of Belton Road
think less money invested a better job
of assessing risk a better job of
sharing risk better feasibility studies
overall just sort of trimming it down
and making it more sustainable so if
we're trimming it down are we still
going to see these Grand Transportation
infrastructure projects deployed in
foreign countries or are they going to
become a thing of the past I don't think
we can say it's the end but the experts
I've spoken to certainly think that
China will stop investing in so many big
infrastructure projects and move into
smaller more Nimble projects so you can
think digital infrastructure like 5G
networks or small green projects like
hydropower plants
so where does this leave Kenya's plans
to connect with Uganda well the
astronaut has made it past Nairobi but
it hasn't quite made it as far as Uganda
as China is yet to give Kenya a loan for
the final part
foreign